all right Republicans you want to win
back the White House in 2024. all right
it's not a secret Pennsylvania is one of
the most important states on the map for
2024 and with Democrats in control of
most of the state government yeah
they've now suddenly decided to
implement automatic voter registration
and it will add voters to the rolls
anytime they get a new driver's license
or renew their driver's license what
could possibly go wrong with that now
former president Barack Obama he loves
the idea and says he hopes more States
will get on board Pennsylvania well it's
not just key to the presidential race
there is a critical Senate race there as
well you have incumbent Democratic
Democrat Bob Casey Jr seeking now a
fourth term now let's take a trip down
memory lane he was running against Rick
Santorum the year is 2006 when he ran
for the first time and Casey said it was
time for a change and specifically
attack then Senator Rick Santorum for
voting with the president 98 of the time
take a look
and I think Tim when you have two
politicians in Washington that agree 98
of the time one of them is really not
necessary we could have we could have a
machine have that kind of votes we need
someone who's going to be truly
independent who has the character in The
Integrity to stand up uh to his party
and his president especially at a time
of War okay one has to go turns out
according to 538 Bob Casey now votes
with Joe Biden a whopping 99 of the time
so by his own logic he's just a rubber
stamp no longer needed joining us now
Dave McCormick who has just announced he
is seeking the Republican nomination to
challenge Casey this year and I think
it's going to be a winnable race for the
Republicans Dave thank you for being
with us
hey Sean good to see you by the way I
will say every single GOP member of the
Pennsylvania delegation has endorsed you
from you know Scott Perry to Brian
Fitzpatrick you know those two don't
agree on very much uh you have
incredible credentials and background uh
tell us why you're doing this and how
you're going to win
well listen
um thanks for having me on the show I'm
doing this uh you know you sound like my
wife why are you doing this the reason
I'm doing this is because I've been
blessed I I feel like I've had all the
opportunities this country has to offer
I went to West Point uh served in combat
in the 82nd Airborne Division and then
was a successful businessman and um and
I think those who to to whom much has
been given much is expected and our
country is headed in a terrible
direction under the leadership of Joe
Biden whether it's the open border
whether it's record high inflation
whether it's uh the fact that we've now
become energy dependent under the
policies of Joe Biden and at every step
along the way Bob Casey has been a
rubber stamp for that failing Joe Biden
agenda and uh I'm I'm really worried the
country that I love and uh have had the
opportunity to serve isn't going to be
the same country for my kids that it was
for me and I feel like we all got to do
our part and I'm going to try to do my
part no I I know you're you're you're
from Pennsylvania
Your Roots Run Deep there and it's been
lifelong but okay so the Democrats are
trying to say no no he lives in
Connecticut you have a house in
Connecticut how will you answer that
predictable attack
yeah well I'm a Seventh Generation
Pennsylvania and I was born there and
raised there uh ran a business there
created jobs there uh but you know like
men and I lived there now but like many
pennsylvanians Sean uh I'm divorced and
uh my youngest daughter is finishing
high school she lives with her mom in
Connecticut and I'm going to go to
Connecticut and spend time with my
daughter and uh and if that's a
political problem then so be it but I
think this is really a distraction
because Bob Casey and the Democrats
don't want to talk about the failing Joe
Biden agenda that the Bob Casey has
rubber stamped every step along the way
and so I'm going to just keep coming
back to the issues of the majority of
pennsylvanians think the country's head
in the wrong direction and Joe Biden has
been lockstep with Bob Casey or Bob's
Casey lockstep with Joe Biden every step
of the way what do you make of the
governor Josh Shapiro's plan to enact
this automatic registration
um is it possible a lot of states have
this that illegal immigration Prince can
get a license in Pennsylvania
well I haven't studied it uh carefully
but I'm I'm very worried about it
because as you know Pennsylvania has
been notorious for for voting
irregularities uh and the the important
things you could do from an election
perspective would be voter ID which is
something that we should have across
Pennsylvania and and really across the
country but what's happening in
Pennsylvania is very interesting the
voter registration Gap is closing and
we've we've gained as Republicans about
800 900 000 voters over the last six or
seven years so this is a state that
Republicans can and should win more
consistently and we need great
candidates we need to support mail-in
ballots and we need to go win elections
so we can take this country in the right
direction well you served as a
paratrooper in the 82nd Airborne you
born and raised and live in Pennsylvania
now America First your whole life
um I think this is a winnable race but
it is critical
for any Republican to win the White
House and control the Senate these are
must that's a must-win state Dave
McCormick we're going to follow this
closely thank you hey Sean Hannity here
hey click here to subscribe to Fox News
YouTube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else